[موسيقى]
تشوف ناس فرحانين تشوف ناس يبكوا وبعدها
تشوف ناس يرقصوا في الجانب الثاني انا
واحد الاحاسيس اللي جاتني كلها داخله في
بعضها ما عرفت نضحك ما عرفت نفرح
[موسيقى]
وهذا خلى خلى الناس اللي تسافر لهذه الدول
خلاها تكون اكثر تجذب لهذه الطريقه لانه
طريقه مختلفه على اللي نعيشوها احنا
كمسلمين او يعيشها معظم الناس كمسيحيين او
كديانات اخرى واصبحت نوع من السياحه وكثير
من الناس لما تسافر لهذه المدن مثل
كاتماندو عاصمه نيبال او مدينه في الهند
تكون اول مكان يزوره هي مكان حرق جثه
الاموات
ومليحه هي لما تروح لهذه الاماكن باش
تتعرف اكثر على ثقافه وديانه وطريقه
طريقه عيش سكان الاصليين تاع المنطقه هذه
[موسيقى]
الولد هو اللي يحرق الاب تاعو او الام
تاعه والبدايه كيما في البدايه الحرق تكون
مختلفه في الاماكن اثنين في الهند مرحلتين
مرحله الاولى يدوروا بالجسم الميت سبع
مرات على النار وبعدها يحطوه في الحطب
الفوق ويبدا الحرق من القلب هذه في مدينه
فرناس في الهند نفس الطريقه سبع دورات
واخر مره اخر باش يبداو الحرق يبدا من
الفم في كاتماندو
وبعدها الابن الابن مرحله الاخيره لما
يتحرق الشخص يحط الرماد بتاعه كامل في
الواد هذا المقدس تاعهم يرموا كامل الرفاه
كامل الاشياء يبقى مثل غبار ما يكون فيه
لا عظام لانه كل شيء يتحلل بالنار
[موسيقى]
دائما بيليه